bonjour je suis sophie sa cage je suis
enseignante chercheuse à l'école
centrale de nantes et je suis spécialisé
en robotique humanoïde les robots de
formules humaine parallèlement à mon
métier j'ai monté j'ai fondé il ya deux
années une association qui est destiné à
mettre à la disposition du public des
connaissances sur les robots et des
compétences pour accompagner la mutation
actuelle de la société avec l'intrusion
des robots parmi nous donc dans cette
dans cette association en l'occurrence
on mène à une recherche une analyse pour
savoir comment dès aujourd'hui les
robots pourraient améliorer notre
quotidien et c'est ça que je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui c'est il ya un projet
qui s'appelle robot tisme et qui raconte
une histoire improbable une aventure
extraordinaire entre quatre partenaires
six jeunes autistes et trois robots nao
alors un robot déjà un robot donc on a
une très belle introduction c'est une
machine une machine exactement quand
votre machine à laver ou votre cafetière
elle a un petit détail supplémentaire à
la des capteurs donc elle peut recevoir
des informations cette machine et avec
un ordinateur elle peut traduire ces
informations pour faire quelque chose
donc le robot il faut le remettre au
niveau de la machine et non pas de la
créature sauf que il y à des auteurs de
science fiction qui nous ont parlé
beaucoup des robots depuis pas mal de
temps
et qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent ils nous
disent que ces robots et leur donne un
vocabulaire humains des gens parle
d'intelligence artificielle dont
l'intelligence est typiquement humain
c'est pas du tout la machine on leur
donne des formes humanoïdes donc ils ont
le même fort que nous on leur prête des
intentions qui sont généralement des
intentions humaine donc ces robots on
les imagine très bien donc deux formes
humaines de préférence armé de tout un
tas de canon et qui vont venir détruire
l'humanité donc se retourner contre nous
ça veut dire que notre culture nous fait
élever ses robots au rang de créatures
or ce sont des créations ce sont des
machines ne pense pas donc on peut très
bien programmer un robot extrêmement
gentil qui va uniquement servir l'être
humain donc c'est ce que je fais moi le
que des robots gentille
donc cette machine c'est nous c'est
notre imagination qui la fait vivre
si on regarde le petit robot nao par
exemple qu'un petit robot humanoïde
maintenant à ses célèbres même quand il
est éteint on peut tomber amoureux de
lui il est très jolie donc même étant on
peut tomber amoureux lui ça veut bien
dire que c'est mon imagination qui va
lui donner une vie des sentiments qui
valent qui valideront lui prêter mon
histoire pour que lui puisse me
répondrez me renvoyer une image celle de
préférence que j'ai imaginé que
j'aimerais moi recevoir donc dans le
cadre des humains donc c'est le robot
compagnon ont déjà à la place tout tracé
puisque dans les films dans les romans
on nous parle d'un robot capable de
penser capable de nous accompagner
capables de nous servir donc le robot
dix compagnons ces robots il peut avoir
n'importe quelle forme on parle de robot
humanoïde bien sûr dans les films ils
sont humanoïde de forme humanoïde
mais ça peut être très bien une prothèse
de jambe par exemple c'est un robot à
une jambe artificielle
vous pouvez vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
acheter un aspirateur robotisés une
tondeuse à gazon c'est maintenant
accessible au niveau des prix il ya déjà
des voitures autonomes qui sont testés
en milieu urbain donc les robots en fait
ils ont ils sont déjà là on les voit pas
forcément beaucoup ils sont déjà
donc ceci étant dit comment on peut
utiliser ces robots dans la société au
niveau par exemple bon dans l'est dans
les services médicaux qu'est ce qu'on va
avoir des robots qui vont faire dans les
entreprises des tâches un petit peu plus
systématique proprement 24 heures sur 24
donc ça oui c'est quelque chose qui nous
fait assez peur on a peur d'être en
place et on peut imaginer donc des
robots qu'on va aimer
on peut imaginer dans les salles
d'opération des robots qui font des
cicatrices plus propre et on peut
imaginer sur les champs de bataille des
des robots qui font des
des meurtres a plus plus proprement
aussi donc ces robots on imagine imagine
facilement en train de faire quelque
chose une machine qui fait quelque chose
maintenant au niveau affectif ce qu'on
voit beaucoup moins c'est l'impact
qu'ils peuvent avoir sur nos sentiments
sur nous en fait et c'est cet aspect du
robot qu'on a utilisées pour les enfants
autistes par exemple et qui pourrait
être utilisé pour tous tous problèmes
psychiques ou psychologiques ou des
petits soucis du quotidien nous
accompagner au quotidien pour nous aider
à vivre avec certaines certaines
défaillances que nous pourrions avoir
par rapport à la société qui les robots
et les enfants autistes ça a commencé
dans les années 80 où une chercheuse
catherine dolto nam a remarqué chercher
anglaise a remarqué que les enfants
autistes et est beaucoup plus ouvert
beaucoup plus réceptifs à des programmes
informatiques donc dans les années 90 à
la proposer en premier robot pour les
accompagner pour les aider à s'ouvrir
avec l'idée de solliciter l'enfant grâce
à ce robot et de petit à petit remplacer
le robot par l'humain donc le principe
c'est que le robot s'exprime comme
l'humain exactement de la même manière
et petit à petit bain les sollicitations
du robot sont remplacées par celles des
humains et du coup leur l'enfant se met
à parler normalement à l'humain ça a
très bien marché à l'aise donc ça c'est
la notion de robots compagnons c'est ce
qu'on appelle un robot compagnon c'est à
dire on nous donne à ce robot un
caractère une identité et il va venir
solliciter l'enfant comme le ferait un
an un être humain normal donc cette
approche fonctionne parce que l'enfant
est ouvert naturellement aux robots mais
c'est gênant c'est l'idée du robot
compagnon allègements en plus c'est très
dangereux à l'idée des robots compagnons
parce que imaginé vivre avec un robot un
robot c'est quelque chose qui vous a
soumis c'est une machine il va faire ce
que vous voulez vous oubliez douala un
robot ce n'est pas son système n'est pas
régulé par un système hormonal
d'accord la communication n'est pas du
tout la même avec une machine qui avec
un être humain les attentes ne sont pas
du tout les mêmes les réponses ne sont
pas du tout les mêmes il va jamais vous
contredire sauf si vous lui demandez de
vous contredire en fait du coup vous
avez ce rapport de maître à esclave qui
s'établit et si vous revenez après avec
des humains classiques comme vous c'est
beaucoup plus sollicitant ça peut être
dangereux en fait c'est à dire vous ne
savez plus comment
et finalement la communication avec les
autres humains donc vous faire un petit
peu attention en plus cette approche de
robot compagnon elle est pas l est pas
forcément acceptable par nous parce qu'à
un moment donné ça nous manqueras
justement parler avec nos lois nos nos
hormones avec nos jeunes ça nous manque
donc basé sur cette réflexion il ya une
autre approche qui a été proposé il ya
deux ans celle du danseur dont ben donc
utiliser le robot comment être danseur
dont vingt danseurs dont vous savez
c'est la personne qui anime les
marionnettes à fils donc c'est celui que
vous ne voyez jamais vous le voyez qu à
travers sa marionnette vous ne
l'entendez qu'à travers sa marionnette
si vous changez le danseur dhombres le
comportement de la marionnette va
changer aussi d'accord donc c'est pas la
même personne c'est à dire que cette
personne va donner à cet objet
normalement inanimé a une âme un
caractère quelque chose qui vient de lui
et on va utiliser le robot exactement de
la même manière pour cette fois ci pas
sollicité l'enfant autiste mais lui
donner une prothèse qui va lui permettre
de s'exprimer
d'accord dans lequel du robot compagnon
il récupère en fait des sollicitations
il a dans la suite dans le cas du robot
extension dont le dans le danseur nombre
il utilise le robot pour combler une
défaillance
donc on a appliqué il ya deux ans cette
approche travers le programme robes
autisme et donc je vais je vais vous
raconter un petit peu tout ça donc la
première séance la première séance
arrive donc quatre partenaires se sont
rencontrés il y avait l'école centrale
intervenait avec l'association
il y avait estimé lui que c'est votre
association nantaise et piste et relu
travailler avec le chu six enfants pour
faire des ateliers sonore un jour l'idée
arrivent en disant mais pourquoi on
mettrait pas les robots carrément avec
les autistes pour changer un petit peu
l'atelier
en juillet les quatre partenaires
discutent un petit peu en septembre le
personnel médical est formé en octobre
les on demande aux jeunes aussi jeune
autiste de dessiner ce qu'ils imaginent
être un robot et en novembre arrive la
première rencontre et cette première
rencontre m'a vraiment marqué pour moi
l'autisme je connais pas l'autisme
des fois il ya personne d'autistes dans
les familles dans ma famille j'ai pas
d'amis qui ont des enfants autistes donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je n'ai
vu qu'à travers quelques films par
exemple man redman ou kim ou globalement
l'autiste est décrit comme une espèce de
calcul est organique
et donc cette première rencontre m'a
choqué parce que pour quatre raisons
donc la première la première impression
vraiment forte
c'est le bruit j'avais tout préparé
comme on avait dit un îlot de travail
trois postes avaient chacun équipé d'un
robot d'un ordinateur donc les enfants
chaque poste pouvait voir les deux
autres travail est d'accord il travaille
face à face donc on aurait mis on allait
mettre deux enfants par par robot
j'attendais près de la porte qu'ils
arrivent tout est allumée y avait plus
qu appliquer le robot allait parler donc
ça c'est prêt les enfants arrivent ils
ont monté les quatre étages par les deux
les escaliers et donc j'ai commencé dès
qu'ils étaient au rez de chaussée à
entendre la rumeur de leur voix et quand
ils ont ouvert la balle à la porte des
escaliers là ça a été un une cascade de
sont en fait de hurlements parce que
quand il s'exprimait s'il avait quelque
chose à dire il avait beaucoup de choses
à dire en fait ils n'attendaient pas que
quelqu'un s'arrête de parler il allait
le hurler comme ça pour le faire
entendre par dessus les autres voies et
du coup mes oreilles entende et 20
personnes alors que mes yeux n'envoyer
que six donc le bruit était vraiment
vraiment très marquant la deuxième chose
qui m'a vraiment marqué c'est l'absence
malgré le bruit c'est l'absence donc
j'étais à côté de la porte ils m'ont
tendu une main qui a qui c'est qui s'est
liquéfié dans ma main c'est à dire ils
ont ils ont fait le geste mais le
contact a été été dans la fuite et le
regard le regard était complètement
fuyant on avait l'impression que ces
corps étaient vides finalement donc ils
se sont installés les infamies en fait
le silence je suis rapproché des tables
je me suis présenté je leur ai dit
comment fait par les eaux
donc ils ont fait parler leurs robots
ils ont fait dire bonjour au bout le
reste de la séance
ça a été comment faire parler le robot
donc ils ont fait dire des choses il
devait taper au clavier et le l'envoyer
robots et le robot hal et le tir quand
quelqu'un avait fini ont tout le monde
sait qu s'arrêtait et tous les autres
écoutent est ce que le petit petit
programmeurs avait fait sur ce robot
avait fait dire aux beaux ils sont
passés très vite dans cette séance de
programmer pour faire ce qu'on leur
disait a programmé pour s'amuser parce
que c'est amusant d'entendre le par
l'eau le robot dire ce qu'on vient de
taper à programmer pour faire écouter
aux autres pour être honnête jamais
entendu un si joli petit robot dire
autant de gros mots en si peu de temps
cette première séance ça a été un petit
peu le dictionnaire argotique et
populaire voyait et très rapidement en
fait ces jeunes dans la première séance
même on commençait à faire un concours
de vulgarité par robot interposés et on
a beaucoup rigolé on a beaucoup ri quand
même parce qu'il y avait des choses
magnifiques et on le savait pas encore
mais en fait on avait déjà gagné c'est à
dire quand un enfant autiste commence à
faire quelque chose dans le but de le
montrer à quelqu'un ça veut dire que
déjà il est sorti de ce qu'il est mais
nous on air on réalisait pas bien sûr on
est en plein travail on n'avait pas
encore la conscience de ça les êtres les
dons qu'il ya une dizaine de séances où
ils ont programmé une histoire une
histoire à quatre voix d'anthony browne
ils ont fait ce spectacle et à la fin on
a fait un spectacle où on inviter une
douzaine de personnes des inconnus donc
savent absolument pas comment ça allait
se passer quelques semaines plus tard
les enfants étaient complètement autiste
il pouvait parfaitement refuser ces
étrangers tout le monde était prévu ça
s'est très bien passé le spectacle les
enfants est assis dans la salle les
étrangers aussi
quarante minutes discussions et ces
échanges et après on a fait un goûter ce
qui était vraiment marquant c'est que
dans cette salle ce jour-là donc
quelques semaines seulement plus tard
après le programme
ce n'était pas des autistes qui étaient
dans la salle c'était vraiment des
adolescents des adolescents normaux qui
avait des choses à dire qu'ils
partageaient leur volume sonore était
tout à fait normal ils attendaient la
fin d'une phrase avant d'intervenir
il parlait tout à fait normalement
laisser ces robots ont changé la vie de
ces jeunes enfants ses six enfants en
fait ils randonnée en fête un avenir ce
qu'on a réalisé aussi c'est que chasser
ans robotique fait sur ce programme le
programme a été mis en place était
équivalente à trois années de thérapie
classique donc ça aussi on l'a on l'a
réalisé
après donc ces robots qui ont changé la
vie de ces jeunes autistes
ils peuvent c'est aujourd'hui donc on
peu après intervenir dans d'autres dans
ce domaine par exemple les jambes
robotisées sont déjà en test sur
quelques pionniers peuvent permettre à
des gens de se remettre un marché
d'avoir une autonomie des gens qui sont
chez eux peuvent avoir un robot pour
venir les aider
pareil de regagner de l'autonomie vous
est maladivement timide vous
vous n'osez pas faire votre déclaration
d'amour vous pouvez envoyer votre bois
votre place ou utiliser le robot dans un
premier temps pour non pas soigné la
timidité
vous n'êtes pas malade c'est pas une
maladie la timidité mais il va vous
apprendre à vivre avec et l'aventuré
robotique allez en route les robots vont
arriver très vite ils sont déjà là on
les voit pas vraiment on les voit qu'à
la télé pour l'instant à cause de
problèmes de sécurité mais en fait ils
sont déjà là et quand ils seront prêts à
rentrer dans la société
ils vont complètement inondées pour
changer nos vies pour le mieux bien sûr
pour nous assister pour nous servir et
pour nous rendre des vies beaucoup plus
belle pour la plupart d'entre nous
donc cette invention valeant les routes
et on peut tous y participer dès
maintenant
même des gens qui ne sont pas de
robotique d'accord les infirmiers des
hospitaliers des gens quelles que soient
leurs compétences peuvent y participer
donc vous pouvez vous joindre à cette
aventure dès maintenant et vous êtes
franchement les bienvenus je vous
remercie